to be the next winner as in and the
winner is the work of the nominees for
best costume design must show a degree
of flair tastefulness and be altogether
pleasing to the eye I believe the same
may be said of Miss Jennifer Beals
talking about a costume without actually
seeing it is like being told about music
without being able to hear it let us
show you some of the works of our
nominees for the best achievement in
costume design Theodorus tech from Deus
and Rolfe four places in the heart
Confucian laura's for 2010
Jenny Beavan and John bright for the
Bostonians
Passage to India
may we have the envelope
and the winner is Theodore piss check
drama -
ladies and gentlemen this is a biggest
and happiest day of my film career I am
very happy improved and for me is it
unbelievable because it is my first
American movie thank you I thank the
Academy of Motion Picture for the honor
and now because the filmmaking is TV I
would like to send my thanks to all my
collaborators in Czechoslovakia in Italy
mainly to my girl assistant Susana
masala but the biggest thing
thanks are to Milosh Foreman because he
made the great film and if the film is
great all other people in this movie
they have ished own chance synchromesh